[Music]
why do solar panels
look so different these days
and why have we started installing them
on top of mountains using them to pave
our roads and
putting them in the middle of our oceans
well if we cover enough of our planet in
solar panels
we'll have a good chance of halting the
planet's
rising temperature and maybe
even cooling it a few degrees but
how would that work could we use the
panels
to reflect the sun's heat into space
how many solar panels would it take to
power
everything on earth and
why could a solar-powered planet be
bad for the environment this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we cooled the earth
with solar panels one way we
could cool the planet is through
something known
as the albedo effect albedo
refers to the amount of light that's
reflected off of a surface
without being absorbed for instance
if all of the earth were covered in ice
the albedo effect would be around 0.84
this means that the earth would reflect
84
of the sunlight that hits it but if the
entire earth was covered by
a forest canopy that number would only
be
about 0.14 only
14 would be reflected meaning that most
of the sunlight
would be absorbed so
if we take a bunch of reflective things
like
solar panels and line the earth with
them
the renewable energy they produce would
help to cool the earth
they'd also reflect a lot of heat away
and then our planet would become cooler
in no time right
[Music]
not exactly
instead of our solar panels cooling the
earth
it could make things hotter instead
although solar panels might look super
reflective to us
they do a pretty bad job of reflecting
sunlight into space
because solar panels are so dark they
absorb sunlight this would
increase the earth's ground temperatures
plus according to the laws of
thermodynamics
we'd be creating even more heat every
time our solar panels
converted solar energy into electricity
ah so let's scratch that whole albedo
idea
if we're going to cool the earth with
solar panels
it will have to be by using them to
completely replace
fossil fuels like oil gas
and coal if we stop using fossil fuels
we won't produce as much greenhouse gas
then we'll stop heating our planet up so
much
so how many solar panels would we need
to power everything on earth
well if we're talking about a typical
350 watt solar panel
it will take about 51.4 billion of them
imagine a solar power plant that covers
299 467 square kilometers
that would be about the size of the u.s
state of arizona to build this massive
project
lots of people would be needed to
manufacture the solar panels
install them and maintain them but
it shouldn't be hard to find a willing
workforce
after all there will be a lot of former
fossil fuel industry employees
looking for jobs so all we have to do is
retrain them and hope they don't
complain too much
we'll be dealing with plenty of other
complaints about this
project people would complain about the
noise during construction
the glare from the panels themselves and
the increased
traffic from panel maintenance vehicles
in residential areas
plus people might be upset about
decreasing
property values especially if their view
changes from enjoying a beautiful
landscape to a massive solar farm
[Music]
for a large project like this
another issue would be land use
using land for the solar farm would mean
a potential loss of habitat and
unlike wind farms solar farms can't
share the land with
agriculture but maybe the most critical
issue would be
producing the solar panels
manufacturing over 51 billion solar
panels would
create harmful emissions to make them
we'd need to use chemicals including
sodium hydroxide and
hydrofluoric acid making the panels
would emit greenhouse gases and create
waste
so if we try to cool down the earth
using solar panels we might end up
creating
more of the emissions that heated our
planet in the first place
maybe we need to stop looking for a
single solution to our planet's heating
problem
if we start thinking of the earth like
one living organism
we'd see that we need to use many
different solutions and
work together to address all its needs
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you